alors que kylie ann m bape est comme une
grande partie des français au chômage
technique et en quarantaine avec ses
proches le prodige de 21 ans a été
victime d'une arnaque c'est une société
de vente de crypto monnaie ces monnaies
virtuelles comme le bitcoin qui sont
souvent l'apanage de nombreux escrocs
dans ce nouveau système est complexe
pour le grand public qui s'est emparé
sans son autorisation de l'image demba
paix une photo accompagnée de la phrase
suivante le dernier investissement de
killian aim map et amis les experts sous
pression et à effrayer les grandes
banques mais ça n'est pas tout car en
plus d'utiliser une photo du joueur pour
attirer de nouveaux clients ce site a
inventé une situation que le footballeur
aurait tenus dans tpm p c'est une
nouvelle possibilité de richesse qui
peut transformer n'importe qui en
millionnaires en l'espace de trois à
quatre mois
je parle de dizaines de milliers d'euros
par jour sur pilote automatique
une citation là encore totalement
inventés vantant les services de bitcoin
trader une fois les clients attirés par
cette publicité mensongère le site
récupèrent leurs coordonnées bancaires
et extorquent de l'argent aux victimes
si kylie ann m bape et n'a pas encore
réagi à cette arnaque et ne semble pas
avoir l'intention d'attaquer le site en
justice
il est loin d'être la seule célébrité
dont l'image est utilisé contre son gré
des arnaques aux cryptes monnaie qui en
2019 aurait rapporté 30 millions d'euros
à leur hauteur pas sûr que ça s'arrête
de sitôt
[Musique]
voilà alors c'est une histoire
incroyable cette histoire de quillanais
mbappé un complètement fou gilles tu
avais entendu parler de cette histoire
car j'en ai entendu parler récemment
ce qui est fou et ce pourquoi ça a
marché il a heureusement qu'il a
débusqué le truc pour porter plainte
c'est que c'est le joueur star il ya des
papes et l'émission star touche pas à
mon pote donc les gens commencent à y
croire avec les crypto monnaie 5
complètement dingue des gens naïve
commencé à y croire
donc comme il a le stade d'un avocat
très fin
autour de lui ils ont tout de suite
intercepté le truc parce que sinon ça
allait faire une polémique infernal los
bravos une rapide avoir réagi très vite